Victoria is with us in Boston hi
Victoria how are you I'm great sir how
are you better than I deserve what's up
awesome so I took your financial piece
class about six years ago I got really
excited about it
up until it got to the hard part the
debt cancellation part or the debt
payment part and I work some local
government so I told myself all apply
for public service loan forgiveness and
ten years I want to worry about it and
so that was again six years ago about a
year ago I started working with a
Primerica financial advisor and we got
on a plan where I would max out my loss
and that put about four hundred dollars
in mutual funds am I also in the last
year purchased a car and so that is
about $200 a month in car loans so my
question is at this point I'm really
praying and considering stopping all of
my investments paying off in a car loan
which I have cash in the bank and then
putting all of that money towards my
student loans that's about $45,000 my
advisor is really recommending that I
don't do that and that I could really
lose out if I paused for the two or
three years it would take me to pay off
that debt I could really be losing out
30 years from now on a lot more if I
just kept that money in the market so
I'm wondering what your advice would be
well you know what my advice would be
don't wander you already knew you took a
class you you know exactly what I think
well yeah I didn't change my advice you
just didn't follow it and now you're
thinking about following it and your
advisor doesn't think my advice is good
right right so you're gonna have to
decide which horse are you going to ride
can you think even like the loss that
there isn't any level of continuing to
contribute and really thinking about
that compound interest that I could
potentially lose Victoria you went to
the class you know what I tell people
you know what I tell people don't you
it's true
temporarily stop all investing and work
your baby steps get out of debt because
your most powerful wealth building tool
is not compound interest your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
dadgum income but that doesn't pay your
Primerica rep any commission you're
getting bad advice I think mm-hmm
but he thinks you're getting bad advice
from me so you're gonna have to decide
aren't you it's true you can't do this
stuff anymore you're gonna have to
decide which horse you're gonna ride and
ride it then okay but you know what I'm
gonna say yes temporarily stop all
retirement yes
pay off your stupid car but I didn't
tell you to buy the stupid car on
payments to start with you know that and
yes I'm gonna tell you to not wait
around on the government forgiveness
because only 96 people have received
that so far I don't think that's a very
good bet I'm gonna pay off my student
loans the shortest path is not compound
interest to wealth the shortest path to
wealth is to get out of debt because you
got control of your income so you need
to decide which advisor you're gonna
follow because your advisors are in
conflict and by the way you ought to
fire one of them or the other so don't
call me for advice anymore if you're
gonna follow his because you know what
I'm gonna say and by the way if you're
gonna follow mine you need to get a
different advisor
because the Primerica guy is not telling
you to do what I'm telling you to do
it's pretty simple
yeah so you it's okay either way I'm not
mad about it I'll be okay either way but
you need to decide a double minded man
is unstable in all his ways decide and
then stick with it ride the horse